hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
from the very beginning of book eight of
his institutes John Cassian is going to
be stressing that it's not enough just
to resist anger or reduce anger it needs
to be rooted out entirely at least for
monks or other religious and perhaps
even for everybody as a whole given the
bad effects that anger is going to have
and so he begins this book by saying
that the deadly poison of anger and
notice that deadly poison
virus right virus originally means
poison we tend to associate it with
these microorganisms that infect us and
I think that that's actually quite a
rich suggestive translation anger is not
merely a poison that we retain within
but something that we become in fact
connected with and perhaps transmit to
others so the deadly poison of anger
needs to be rooted out erwendum it needs
to be pulled out by its very Roots it
needs to be exterporated as another way
of translating it from where from our
entire soul from the innermost
recesses of our soul or to use another
term that comes up a lot here our heart
so this is a completely Zero Tolerance
view on anger and why well because it
has so many deleterious effects and I'm
just going to read through these and we
can think about how many of these there
are he says so long as anger remains in
our hearts and it blinds with hurtful
Darkness the Eye Of the Soul we can
neither require right judgment and
discretion nor gain the Insight which
Springs from an honest gaze the ripeness
of counsel okay so what do we have going
on there anger has what we could call
epistemological effects it makes us
unable to use our own higher mental
faculties ourselves or even to benefit
from the advice and counsel being
provided by other people so that's one
main set of effects
then he goes on and he says nor can we
be partakers of life or retentive of
righteousness we can't remain just we
can't do what we ought to do or even
have the capacity for Spiritual and True
Light nor can we become partakers of
wisdom even though we're considered Wise
by Universal consent there are people in
the world who everybody says oh they're
so wise but anger rests as he brings up
in the bosom of fools
then he goes on and says nor can we even
attain Immortal life even though we're
accounted prudent in the opinion of
everybody why because another proverb
anger destroys even the prudent so again
epistemological effects nor shall we be
able with clear Judgment of heart to
secure the controlling power of
righteousness even though people
consider us to be perfect and holy for
and he brings up another one the wrath
of man work it works not the
righteousness of God
so what have we seen emphasized here on
the one hand problems uh on the
cognitive side we can't see things
correctly on the other part problems
with Justice righteousness fairness we
are going to tend to do the wrong thing
and to think that we're doing the right
thing in the process he goes on and he
says nor can we secure any ripeness of
counsel even though we appear to be
weighty and endowed with the utmost
knowledge why because an angry man acts
without counsel nor can we be free from
dangerous disturbances nor without sin
even though no sort of disturbances be
brought Upon Us by others why one last
scriptural quote a passionate man
engenders quarrels an angry man digs up
sins and so this is really quite
interesting isn't it all these different
effects coming from giving in to anger
so so if that's really the case then it
would make sense as Cassie and saying
that we we need to tear up Anger from
the roots and so he's supplying us with
a whole bunch of reasons here a little
bit later in the text he tells us that a
monk aiming at Perfection striving after
Perfection tenderly like reaching their
handout for you know being without
blemish and Desiring to strive lawfully
in spiritual combat uh fighting you know
should be free of all sin of anger and
wrath and we see repeated here this
constant conjunction anger era wrath
that John Cassian uses over and over
again probably following from the Greek
orge anger thumos which can be
translated as the faculty of anger anger
itself Wrath and so he's constantly
pairing these together the monk needs to
free themselves from that and so he
cites this uh biblical text let all
anger be taken away uh along with wrath
and clamor evil speaking right and so he
says here's how we should interpret this
when he says and this is Paul to the
Ephesians let all anger be taken away
from you
he's not making exceptions he's not
saying let all anger be taken away from
you except when anger is necessary or
anger is useful in that case don't take
that anger away because obviously it's
serving some sort of purpose Cassian
says that's too easy a mistake to make
people will create excuses find you know
reasons why in this case they can make
an exception and Cassian says no no no
you cannot do that you um have to take
away all of the anger and he says if
need be should at once treat an earring
brother in such a way while he manages
to apply a remedy to one Afflicted he
may not by his wrath involve himself in
a more dangerous malady so the Healer of
others as he's going to say has to be
healthy himself and free of afflictions
of weakness anger is a weakness
according to Cassian and according to
the scriptural text that he's bringing
up both from Paul and from the wisdom
literature right which has a lot to say
about anger so he's bringing together
kind of a coherent perspective on this
there is one exception that we should
point out so Cassian in a few later
chapters will say
it could be useful to get angry in one
kind of situation when we are getting
angry at our own vices sins faults right
the things that are screwing us up the
things that are actually removing us
from the path of perfection
so this is not getting angry at other
people we can't even say oh they're
making me angry therefore I have to you
know go off in the desert he talks about
that as well says you've gotta if you're
gonna get angry at all
get angry at your own vices the vices
that are being described here in this
Treatise which is largely about the
eight Capital vices the vices that lead
to other vices
and get angry at the very anger that you
feel that's kind of a reflexive meta
anger you could call it and so that is
the only exception that he's making
there getting angry at other people or
with inanimate things always a bad thing
getting angry with the parts of
ourselves that are damaged and leading
us astray that could be okay of course
you don't want to go too far even with
that he brings up interestingly the Old
Law meaning the uh the Jewish scriptures
prior to Christianity and he says you
know a lot of people will sometimes
portray it as like we've got the new law
the gospel which is so nice this Jesus
guy is coming along and you know not
preaching a god of Vengeance and then
we've got the Old Law which tends to be
you know harsher and and you know meaner
and Cassian rejecting that he's saying
why should we spend any more time over
evangelist evangelic meaning from the
gospels an Apostolic precepts so why
should we uh just focus on those when we
can look at the Old Law itself which is
thought to be somewhat slack it guards
against the same thing when it says you
shall not hate your brother in your
heart and again be not mindful of the
injury of your citizens and again the
ways of those who preserve the
recollection of wrongs are towards death
so he says you see there too that
wickedness is restrained not only in
action but also in the secret thoughts
it's commanded that hatred be utterly
rooted out from the heart and not merely
retaliation but the very recollection of
a harm done now hatred and anger not
exactly the same thing but closely
connected aren't they so Cassian is
saying there's a continuity here in
these religious teachings between what
we find in the Hebrew scriptures and
what we find in the later Christian
scriptures coming back to the gospel
where in you know Matthew for example we
have these injunctions against anger
he's going to say that you know what's
going on in the gospels is that we are
not just supposed to control anger you
could say in um words or deeds he says
if we want to gain the substance of that
Divine reward we have to root out Anger
from our innermost soul
it will not be of any good to have
checked anger in words and not to have
shown it in Deeds if God from whom the
secrets of the heart are not hid sees
that it remains in the secret recesses
of our bosom the word of the Gospel bids
us destroy the roots of our faults
rather than the fruits because when the
incitements are removed then these you
know Roots will not forth shoots anymore
and the mind will be able to continue in
patients and Holiness so in order to do
this we have to go within we have to
look at why we get angry about stuff and
we have to start to apply some remedies
and he goes on and he says we have to
cut off anger and hatred and this is
what is actually being commanded in the
gospels why because these lead to murder
and violence and so you know the the old
law said thou shall not murder well
you're not supposed to get angry and
hate your brother or whoever else in
your heart because that's what leads to
it and then there's one interesting
discussion here in the next chapter
so there were a number of different
manuscripts circulating around of all
these early Christian texts that
eventually got bound into What's called
the New Testament
and some of the manuscripts had an extra
word in there the Greek word akos so uh
whoever gets angry with his brother
will be liable to the Judgment now some
of the manuscripts said whoever gets
liable whoever gets angry with his
brother without cause acos will be
liable to the Judgment so some Christian
authors including you know for example
later on Augustine and chrysostom will
say all right what does this mean to get
angry with cause without cause John
Cassian is saying it doesn't matter
there's no acos there's no reason you
should be angry at your brother as a
matter of fact don't pay attention to
those manuscripts and he he makes a
claim here that we find you know the
right version written in many modern
copies and all of the ancient ones so we
should put aside that as a Temptation
and he finishes the treaties or he
finishes that chapter of the treaties
rather by talking about remedies how to
deal with this disease so he says one of
the things we can do is make up our mind
we should never be angry at all whether
for good or bad reasons as we know we're
going to lose all these these things the
light of discernment Good Counsel so
does this mean never ever get angry or
hide your anger no because pushing your
anger within as he talks about in other
chapters just leads to passive
aggressive behavior it doesn't deal with
it doesn't root it out
we should make up our mind that it's not
a good thing for us ever to get angry
that means that we're
forming a way of working at things that
we can work towards
another very interesting thing that he
tells us
Don't Pray when you're angry
now
a lot of people would probably say well
that's exactly when you need to be
calling on God's help
Cassian is looking at that other thing
from the gospels that if you are have if
your brother has anything against you
and you bring your gift to the altar
leave your gift there go be reconciled
with your brother then come back and
make your gift and he says praying is a
sacrifice praying is a giving a gift at
the altar so until you get over your
anger don't pray just focus on getting
over your anger and he tells us that we
should also keep our end in mind what he
calls the uncertain condition of
humankind we should realize daily we're
soon to depart from the body and all our
continents and Chastity our renunciation
or of our possessions our contempt of
wealth our efforts and fastings and
vigils all this kind of stuff that monks
do and maybe other people do
will not help us at all is solely on
account of anger and hatred
Eternal punishments are awarded by the
judge of the world so anger is a serious
problem and if we don't get rid of it
all this other stuff that we do might be
for nothing so uh very strong arguments
and considerations given here on the
part of John Cassian for why it is that
we should root anger entirely
out of our hearts souls or Minds